an estimated 1.2 million Americans were
left out of the federal stimulus program
because of who they married their
us-born children did not get the benefit
either
here's Adriana Diaz with why these
mixed-status families were excluded as
such a time of need
Caitlyn Jimenez a nurse from Wisconsin
was counting on the stimulus her
husband's restaurant hours were cut in
the shutdown and they have two girls to
support we needed it just as bad as
anybody else needed but Caitlyn and
other Americans like Laurie from
Illinois were ineligible for the
stimulus it does make me feel kind of
like a second-class citizen in a way
just for who I married the cares act
left out couples who file jointly if one
spouse lacks a social security number
even if the other is a US citizen
sparking outrage how dare you cause me
and my kids are being affected Laurie's
husband who was undocumented and didn't
want to be interviewed doesn't have a
Social Security number
neither do many immigrants here legally
on visas or foreigners married to
Americans abroad instead he pays taxes
with an individual tax ID number like
many undocumented immigrants proof of
paying taxes can help their immigration
cases how do you feel about your young
daughter not receiving this benefit
that's the most painful part like even
if they didn't want to give it like say
like punish us because of you know he's
not a United States it's an like how
could you punish a child that was born
here like an innocent child I don't
think any other country would really do
this during a you know like a pandemic
or a crisis the cares Act made an
exception for active-duty military in
mixed-status families but not veterans
in the same position families nationwide
have sued and in its response the
government defended the policy the yeas
are 220 mule ascents to all taxpayers
regardless of status but there's
opposition this bill does what it gives
tax dollars to illegal immigrants what
do you say to the argument that some
lawmakers have put forward which is they
don't want undocumented folks to benefit
in any way we as a family we
you know put that money back into the
economy Caitlyn's older daughter worries
about her dad who found a new job in
landscaping I get nervous that he's
gonna like get sick Wayne goes to work
her father Samuels used to be
undocumented but after a seven-year
process
he just got a green card and a social
but it was too late for the stimulus
just feeling like you know we we didn't
matter as a family you feel like you
don't matter yeah in your own country
yeah a citizen second-guessing her own
status in America for CBS this morning
Saturday Adriana Diaz Waukesha Wisconsin
so that argument that you know
immigrants are undocumented immigrants
don't pay into the system if they're
paying federal income taxes it seems
like that's a stipulation that should be
heard yeah it is interesting if you're
paying why aren't you able to benefit
from it